people are
making a head
decision that should be a heart decision
those are heart question not hard but
like heart what you should do with your
life how you should live your purpose
like that's heart and we're trying to
answer with our head but you can't
answer a heart question with your head
we end up doing The Logical safe
practical thing as opposed to doing the
thing that hasn't been done before and
you'll always be discontent you live in
discontent if you're never doing the
thing that you want
would love to be doing and you're just
doing a thing because it's trending or
there's some new tech out or because
your mom wanted you to go take that
career or because of Someone Like You is
supposed to do you'll never be happy and
you'll always jump from one thing to the
next